son alrededor de las 22:30 del 14 de
julio de 2016
cerca de 30.000 personas asisten al
tradicional espectáculo de fuegos
artificiales en el Paseo de los ingleses
de Niza es en ese momento cuando el
terrorista Mohamed lawes Bullet lanza su
ataque mortal a bordo de un camión
frigorífico desde 19 toneladas el
tumecino de 31 años se abre paso a
través del control de seguridad y
conduce directamente hacia la multitud
creando pánico
al día siguiente el fiscal de la
república se pronuncia luteísta tiene
apellido
el terrorista disparó varias veces
contra tres policías cerca del hotel
los policías respondieron y persiguieron
al camión que siguió su curso durante
unos 300 metros
los policías consiguieron neutralizarlo
disparando a la altura del palacio del
Mediterráneo el terrorista fue
encontrado muerto en el asiento del
pasajero
su carrera mortal solo duró 3 minutos
pero el daño fue altísimo 86 personas
murieron entre ellas muchos niños y más
de 450 resultaron heridas otros cientos
quedaron traumatizados
observé impotente ese jueves todo lo que
pasaba
como el camión se alejaba el camión
acribillaba a la gente
en mis brazos y el camión pasó a 50
centímetros de su pierna así nos
salvamos luego en la playa también fue
terrible vigente morir delante de mí
escasos metros
durante días Muchas personas anónimas
acudieron a presentar sus respetos a las
víctimas en el lugar pero también en el
extranjero en mausoleo improvisados la
investigación se centró entonces en
determinar si el terrorista tuvo
Cómplices que lo ayudaran a obtener sus
armas y su camión varias personas fueron
rápidamente detenidas